Welcome to The David Pakman Show, I am Jesse
Moore, sitting in for David while he is luxuriating
on vacation today in America, especially related
to covid, there are two camps of people.
You have the camp that is concerned for their
fellow citizens and want to stop the onslaught
of the virus that has resulted in the deaths
of over 600000 Americans and millions worldwide.
And the other camp is comprised of people
who are colluding against the first camp.
Fortunately not, unfortunately, fortunately,
we seem if you're watching this and you're
of like mind, we're on the first team.
And fortunately, now we have a government
that is standing in the gap for those most
in need relative to protection, I hold in
my hand here a memorandum for all Department
of Defense employees written by Lloyd Austin,
former general and now secretary of defense.
And he is
mandating with the president's approval seeking
President Biden's approval to have all military
personnel and Department of Defense employees
vaccinated by mid-September.
I'm going to read a little bit from this memorandum
because I believe it's important to give context
of the words of the leaders.
Over the last week, I have consulted closely
with the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff,
the secretaries of the military departments,
the service chiefs and medical professionals.
I appreciate greatly the advice and counsel
they provided based on these consultations
and on additional discussions with leaders
of the White House covid Task Force.
I want you to know that I will seek the president's
approval to make the vaccines mandatory no
later than mid-September or immediately upon
the U.S. Food and Drug Administration.
Leisinger, whichever comes first.
By way of expectation, public reporting suggests
that the Pfizer vaccine could achieve full
FDA
licensure early next month to defend this
nation.
We need a healthy and ready force.
I strongly encourage all DOD military and
civilian personnel, as well as contractor
personnel to get vaccinated now and for military
service members to not wait for the mandate.
All FDA authorized covid-19 vaccines are safe,
highly effective.
They will protect you and your family.
They will protect your unit, your ship and
your coworkers, and they will ensure we remain
the most lethal and ready force in the world.
Now, many of you probably have no idea who
I am, but for the edification of those who
don't know, I served in the United States
Marine Corps for many years and there is sure
to be some backlash among some of the more
right wing nutters in the military.
And rest assured, there are many of them.
When I was in the Marine Corps,
they did this DNA testing where they took
a drop of blood and there was an outcry from
many acting as though there was a conspiracy
afoot.
And the same thing is going to happen here.
Now, what I find interesting is the fact that
the the same the same people in the camp who
talk about the military being too sensitive
and being too woak are the same that are going
to act like this is an imposing some kind
of a problem on the military members who are
largely.
Dutiful people who care about their oath to
support and defend the Constitution, who care
about their country, who care about their
neighbors.
That's not the case with everybody.
But it matters that our military get vaccinated
not just for the communities in which they
live, but so we have a viable ready force
in case something does happen
where they need to be deployed.
Now, President Biden released a statement
and in part he said, I strongly support Secretary
Austins message to the force today on the
Department of Defense's plan to add the covid-19
vaccine to the list of required vaccinations
for our service members.
Not later than mid-September.
Secretary Austin and I share an unshakable
commitment to making sure our troops have
every tool they need to do their jobs as safely
as possible.
These vaccines will save lives.
That's what this is about.
Saving lives.
This is about protecting lives.
And in a not so abstract way, isn't that indeed
what the military is there for, to protect?
Lives.
To care for the citizenry of this country.
To not be vaccinated goes against
that ethos.